46 seconds of two logos you know Ridley
Scott's last sci-fi film also opened
with gorgeous aerial footage of an alien
planet that movie was called Prometheus
here's hoping this is one of the only
similarities between the two films in
case you confused it with regular old
some part of Mars Sue Storm still can't
find Reed Richards on those satellites
well I'll keep checking mission
commander shuts to team members radios
off because they're annoying and I am
personally holding this mission
commander responsible if anything goes
wrong and one of these guys ends up
tragically dead but not dead but
actually abandoned how many samples do
we need commander grams each trained
mission ready astronauts know this
information in their sleep before even
leaving Earth but expositional commander
you should come inside they're gonna
wanna see this
you should come take a look at this
cliche how did this storm approach this
quickly without them deciding to scrub
far enough ahead to not have to walk
with a mad and zero visibility
either NASA warned them too late or they
acted too slowly but this planetary
escape shouldn't be anywhere near this
close well I thought you said map is
gonna tip at twelve point three what
gives looks like every science fiction
movie taking place on another planet
there's someone outside the ship taking
entirely too long to get back in it so
we can have a race against the clock
yeah good thing marks unconsciousness
had a convenient time limit dude now
you're gonna bleed out maybe you knew
that but Jesus maybe you got some
medical supplies ready first Jason
Bourne astronaut also Jesus how did he
even survive this overnight on a
different planet movie think
self-surgery on mars isn't gonna make me
pass a also scenes that make you upset
that the cute concessions girl was able
to upsell you from a medium to a large
popcorn and suggestive sold you the
Junior Mints wait it's not over
did he staple his stomach back together
that's a loose end better tie that up it
is my opinion that Rubik's Cube still
sells millions of toys every year
because they're in every movie you watch
so I got to figure out a way for grown
eating while talking to an unseen
audience
movie attempts to make botany cool the
Martian where you learn all the ways
that being scientifically literate can
save your life but but dr. Tyson I mean
come on botany the Martian with fluency
and science technology engineering and
math
rule all decisions of survival but maybe
you should think of it this way dr.
Martian where science not human emotion
drives the plots humor interpersonal
relations tension and suspense this is
what you get when you argue a Martian
will you experience love/hate and the
anxiety pride and heroism all through
the lens of science man of science
judges other people and that major wound
he had three days ago is pretty much
gone Mars mission astronauts were sent
to Mars with happy days episodes instead
of like the wire Breaking Bad or any
amazing TV show made between happy days
and this futuristic mission to Mars
premature celebration they decided to
have marks funeral about a month after
he supposedly died and yes we accounted
for the fact that a Mars day is only 40
minutes longer than an Earth Day this
guy's name and title appear on screen
after he's already been in the movie a
good while now also Teddy Sanders that's
the name you went with for your NASA
director why not stuffy Williams sir
Sparky Smith in case she confused it
with East Houston Idaho like those
assholes in Superman too did Jesus
Christ
enough with the descriptions already
you're gonna tell me the time - okay
thanks I was wondering I'm gonna die up
here that's funny man but guess what
you're the guy who pressed play on turn
the beat around for some ridiculous
reason I'm gonna have to science they
get out of this the Martian where the
protagonist survives not on wit prayer
or Hope but on sciencing this down of
everything this is officially the least
disco song she owns
did neither mark nor the rest of the
crew bring their own tunes to Mars with
them also amazing the least disco song
she owns just happens to be something
that plays ironically with the current
situation person stuck with narrow music
selection ends up dancing to a song he
used to hate cliche don't say bring him
home alive and so yeah that's terrible
Danny no more Vincent on TV copy that
people can't learn from their mistakes
and we're racist sorry Vincent Sean Bean
isn't dying in this scene I know what
I'm gonna do and I'm gonna keep the
people watching this journal in suspense
because I know this will be a movie
someday in case you confused it with
Pasadena Thailand a number of bikes and
electric golf carts in the scene makes
me wonder exactly how much of this
film's budget was paid for by anti oil
interests man it sure is a good thing
Mars decided to chill with the deadly
sandstorms that drove the rest of the
team off the planet nearly killed mark
am i right thankfully he's left to do
all this from the Mars equivalent of San
Diego weather I realize he was trained
out the ass before this mission that's
all I start on tar but he's a goddamn
botanist how does he have any knowledge
of the decades earlier Pathfinder
missions technology thankfully nASA has
been using universal power chords for 40
years so that if he gets stranded
somewhere you can just power up old tech
with new batteries obvious potatoes
steam CGI is obvious also he brought
salt and pepper and olive oil to this
meal but chose to ignore them all and
just use ketchup ladies and gentleman I
give you super nerd back amazingly
despite her nerd status mark is easily
able to access her personal computer
with no password speeding up the footage
is perhaps the only way to make this
figuring out how to communicate via
still images and hexadecimal seen not
100% boring is this part of the movie is
silent because the studio needed a pg-13
rate and if you hear more than twice in
a movie that is not rated our society
devolves into a Neill Blomkamp movie I
mean one of the odds Jessica Chastain
and Matt Damon with both co-star and
epic space adventures in back-to-back
ears that's just goofy oh this guy
survives an awful lot on this planet
what does dr. Kayson have to say about
this the Martian may be the first sci-fi
blockbuster ever in which nobody dies I
think he means that in a positive way
and I'm inclined to agree but the fact
that he does survive so much in this
movie as simple as hell every day I go
outside and look at the vast horizons
wow this movie's unnecessary repeat
repetition of watney's text messages
clearly added to the 2 hour of 12-minute
runtime I think they use the slow motion
is also responsible for this movies in
easily long runtime this movie is a lot
like castaway only Matt Damon's hair
never grows and will cancel the inspires
sir if that ever got out it's on me
evidence that the Martian movie is
fantasy all who make important decisions
are scientifically literate they gave
them two weeks so naturally they took
twice as long and probably still won't
work drunk on a 10-point fight so let's
all start cheering before the probe
actually gets into space I'm blaming
this one on the jinxing people inside
that room it's a lot to ask thankfully
for this movie what he keeps talking
even when he's only typing as opposed to
video recording his every movement hey
just because it says China in the name
of the building doesn't mean you
suddenly stop giving me both the city
and the country it's it I need to be
spoon-fed also suddenly China to the
rescue
clear pandering to Chinese audiences in
order to be one of the lucky movies that
go to China is clear pandering genre one
Supporter puto oh yeah but would you doc
you should woman should keep on the
shaman and not only are they going to
help it's clear they didn't need to help
making them that much more heroic I mean
play the march of the volunteers while
you're at it the hell is project Elrond
have I ever mentioned help and weird it
is to have comedic actress Kristen Wiig
and this decidedly not comedy movie Hey
the Golden Globes in their
classifications despite a few laughs
this is not a comedy Elrond because he's
a secret meeting I love the fact that
Boromir is the one explaining this and
they're making a cheeky in-joke but many
times the things that you enjoying our
sins so what I'm proposing is
we start accelerating immediately wait
wait I saw this in Star Trek for the boy
jump only that movie had better use of
colorful metaphors rich yes sir
get out thanks for being helpful now
leave this up for white people to decide
when this is over I'll expect your
resignation he means death right I mean
this is Sean Bean we're talking about
here the MAV for Ares 4 is already there
at the Schiaparelli crater just waiting
you mean a rocket full of pink supplies
has been sitting there this whole time
seems like they could have cut down on
that we have to rescue mark by doing it
fast and cutting as many corners as
possible decision making that provided
this movie with so many ups and downs
originally Lewis's love of disco is a
never-ending source of filler
once again before the probe is even in
space these assholes celebrate
prematurely
get historically icy relations between
the Chinese and American governments are
glossed over for the sake of a single
white guys survival just as I've been
predicting for years and what do you say
dr. Tyson evidence that the Martian
movie is fantasy the USA and China
cooperate with one another in space
everything's done with computers but
somehow this docking procedure requires
a spacewalking astronaut ballet and
nothing important happened in space or
on Mars for seven whole months if he's
400 plus souls into this thing and where
the the back wounds come from does he
Batman did the magic scissors mark was
using to cut his own hair for months and
months get dull or something
the guy was perfectly groomed until it
was time to show how horrible his
condition was yeah the problem is the
intercept velocity that means well the
contents of Mars orbit otherwise there's
no valve enough fuel to that's gonna
make it home
a minute ago Donald Glover came in and
said here's the calculations they all
check out and they clearly did it
because the hurry screw ran the
calculations and confirmed it now
suddenly the Hermes can't make the full
trip because this movie needs more
challenges if we go remote we can lose
the control panels in fact all of this
is something that could have been
calculated before the Hermes started
going back to Mars it's absolutely
insane all these problems are just now
being discovered
I highly doubt they would have
considered Rich's plan viable at all
also by this point where we're sending
man missions to Mars why isn't the
infrastructure in place to have fueling
stations just in case something like
this happens there hello why not back
the Chinese brew with some fuel or send
another probe toward the Hermes wow
they're going tomorrow so they can meet
up with it later now you might say
that's impossible but we're about to see
literally everything go wrong and one
ship trying to perfectly time and catch
a stripped-down rocket and everyone
lives so checkmate Marquand it would be
amazing at cinemasins
near
your Mars mission astronauts have access
to ecto cooler whew Times Square is like
New Year's Eve waiting for the fate of
Mark Watney it's not a play-by-play
where all the action is televised it's
just watching the damn news for Christ's
sake
again I grant you this would be a super
watched television event but why is the
movie so convinced people like watching
TV outdoors and humongous groups I'm no
NASA dude but this tarp with open gaps
instead of the windows and rocket op
situation leaves me more than a little
uncomfortable is this thing headed into
space with a tent on the nose
how about wind resistance and other
science facts well as someone told me
long ago I really should relax and
here's someone else telling us to relax
in the Martian movie they got crucial
science right while enhancing the story
by fictionalizing the science that
remained we agree but we're keeping that
sin damn it they're broadcasting this
live I mean at least use a 10 second
delay in case he dies right intercept
velocity will be 11 meters per second I
can make that work why so confident you
clearly told us earlier that at 5:00 you
could grab him but at 10 it was gonna be
like jumping onto a speeding train now
it's one louder in your leg no prob
chief Sue Storm kisses Bucky in space
and all I can think is that this is
Fox's desperate plea to marry marble
franchises this movie's climactic rescue
plan involves intentionally blowing up
part of the spaceship then that's some
bullsh incredibly this works the movie
would have been fine just to catch this
dude in the way they plant which was
already hard enough but then they had to
make it even more ridiculous I think the
writers had to meet a quota of Louis's
music is terrible jokes so someone not
only had the idea but then also stocked
Times Square buildings with confetti on
the off-chance want it would not only be
rescued but the tens of thousands would
venture out to watch that rescue in
Times Square somehow America's
adventures as an international celebrity
did not bring him thousands of
supermodels to choose as his sister
wives that said this flat forward is so
unnecessary that even if wanting wins
the lottery and gets blown by
supermodels in the scene I still won't
care about it now you can either accept
that or you can get to work even wolf
beer he's teaching future astronauts now
scene is even both beer and super
annoying and already credits have begun
and there's still way more movie left
but nothing we couldn't do without
that's for sure
not only did Sean Bean not die in this
movie but he ends up teaching youth golf
the Mars terraforming project will be
the greatest achievement in the history
of human exploration
we'd like to take a moment here for a
special thank you to our friend dr. Neil
deGrasse Tyson for once again helping us
find sins and the wins in a popular
science fiction film the honor was all
ours
it's important to note that we're a
couple of Jackass comedians and that
could be fun but there are people all
over YouTube entertaining while actually
educating and talking about important
stuff and dr. Tyson is one such
individual by way of a star talk channel
D like science D like space you should
be subscribed to Startalk they do great
engaging stuff like this we're gonna go
to Mars dude do you see engineering
challenges to that or is it only no no
no this is a very serious question
engineers love a challenge so don't tell
me don't don't play that with me a B
bring it on don't bring it on don't even
so my question is is it just a matter of
money or even if I gave you as much
money as you want you might not be able
to solve some of the engineering problem
oh we can solve the plan that that's
know we can solve yeah because we Land
Rover from a freaking rocket crane right
we can solve the problems you can check
out more of that video below or just
click then subscribe right now to show
dr. Tyson how much you appreciate is
pitching in for one of our since videos
or you know many of us actually
important contributions to society just
don't subscribe no signature required
thank you again good sir we had a blast
getting corrected and clarified by it we
kind of hurt you you are awesome and now
for the outtakes Matt Jamie
see you managed to get your shirt off
Brando's got what plants crave it's got
electrolytes
I mean it's 50 million miles away from
home he thinks he's totally alone he
thinks we gave up on him the man is
hurtin he is alone tired and he hasn't
seen diddly squat from anybody down here
feel like I should live with that
decision and I have today is my birthday
and it's a special one because you told
me you once told me that when you came
back we might be the same age and today
I'm the age you were when you left one
does not simply walk into Mordor I've
been thinking about laws on Mars the
metric system never panned out we all
had rulers with inches on one edge and
centimeters on the other I pronounced it
centimeters instead of centimeters and
nobody ever corrected me they just let
me walk around stupid so I'm not really
upset we never crossed over although
it's helpful to know the conversions
when I go to Europe the leader bottle is
the only thing that ever caught on
because it's a nicer word leader than a
quart my name is Max my world is fire
and blood but I need you to stop staring
and help me with the tether